Okay, now that we have looked at how to
write sentences in the language of logic
and also looked at how to
rewrite the sentences, for
example by eliminating implication,
let us now look at
what kinds of rules of inference can
be implied and how can we apply them.
One rule of inference is
called Modus Ponens, and
many of you may already
be familiar with it.
If I'm given a sentence s1
which says p implies q, and
another sentence S2 which says p,
then I could infer q from it.
p implies q and p, therefore q,
this symbol stands for therefore.
Let's take an example, so imagine that
I'm given that feathers imply bird.
And I'm also given
that feathers is true.
Then, I can infer that
bird must be true.
Now we can connect
this to a logic agent.
Imagine that there is a robot and
I bootstrap that robot with
the knowledge that feathers imply bird.
Now the robot goes to a new
region in the country and
finds some animal which has feathers.
The robot cannot conclude that
that particular animal is a bird.
So the first sentence came from
something that I had bootstrapped into
the knowledge of the robot.
The second sentence came from
the percepts of the robot.
And the third sentence came
from its logical inferencing.
And this is how the robot can,
in fact, go about making sound,
complete inferences that
are guaranteed to be correct.
Here is a second rule of inference,
this is called Modus Tollens.
So again I have sentence S1, p implies
q, and I have a second sentence, not q.
And therefore,
I can inference that not p.
So let us take an example
of Modus Tollens.
Imagine that there is a robot
that has been programmed,
bootstrapped with the knowledge
feathers imply bird.
So that's part of its
knowledge base already.
This robot goes to a new country and is
talking to the people in that country,
and the people tell the robot a story
about an animal that is not a bird.
Therefore the robot may infer that
that animal must not have feathers.
So this is coming from
the knowledge that is bootstrapped.
This is coming from the new
percept from the story.
And this is coming from
the logical inference.
And once again, the logical inference
is guaranteed to be sound and complete.
>> You may already be familiar with
this line of reasoning because this is
another way of phrasing
a contrapositive,
that we see in other areas of logic.